IF NEWS HAPPEN WE WILL GO THERE.
FIRST UP TO SPEED ON WHAT IS
HAPPENING IN WASHINGTON.
THE CRACK POLITICAL TEAM OVER AT
THE "WASHINGTON POST" UNCOVERED
A BRAND NEW SPECIES OF FAKE NEWS
YOU NEED TO KNOW ABOUT:
ORIGINARY LEFT WINGONES.
-- WING MOBS.
THEY CAST THE TRUMP RESISTANT
MOVEMENT AS AN ANGRY MOB.
THE "WASHINGTON POST" WANTS YOU
TO KNOW THESE MOBS ARE NOT REAL.
THEY ARE AN ILLUSION.
THAT MAY SURPRISE YOU.
YOU MAY HAVE SEEN VIDEOS OF
PROMINENT REPUBLICANS BEING
CHASED OUT OF RESTAURANTS BY
PROGRESSIVES AND READ HOW A
REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMAN WAS SHOT
WITH A RIFLE BY A BERNIE SANDERS
SUPPORTER.
AND COLLEGE CAMPUSES DESCEND
INTO RIOTING BECAUSE
CONSERVATIVES SHOWED UP TO TALK.
AND GROUPS OF HYSTERICAL YOUNG
PEOPLE WHY WOULD AT LAWMAKERS.
ALL OF THIS MAY HAVE GIVEN YOU
THE MISTAKEN IMPRESSION THERE IS
A THREAT OF DISORDER AND
LAWLESSNESS FROM THE LEFT
BUILDING IN THIS COUNTRY.
SOME FUNDED BY A MAN THE
"WASHINGTON POST" DESCRIBES AS A
PHILANTHROPIST.
THIS IS RACISM.
IT'S DESIGNED SAYS THE POST FOR
THE BENEFIT OF WHITE VOTERS
PARTICULARLY MEN.
THE ANGRY MOBS YOU THOUGHT YOU
WERE WATCHING ON TELEVISION ARE
MERELY A HALLUCINATION CONCOCTED
BY FOX NEWS.
YOU CAN WAKE UP NOW.
NONE OF IT IS REAL.
IT'S 1996 AGAIN.
WAIT, HAS ANYONE TOLD THE ANGRY
LEFT WING MOBS ABOUT THIS?
THEY BELIEVE THEY EXIST.
IN PORTLAND THEY ARE BLOCKING
TRAFFIC AND BREAKING THINGS AND
SCREAMING AT OLD LADIES IN WHEEL
SHARE.
THEY DON'T GET THE "WASHINGTON
POST" IN OREGON.
WATCH.
>> [SCREAMING].
>> [BLEEP].
>> [SHOUTING].
>> [SCREAMING].
>> [BLEEP].
>> Tucker: DON'T BELIEVE YOUR
LYING EYES.
SOME REPORTS DESCRIBE THE
PROTESTORS AS ANTIFA.
OTHERS SAY THEY ARE BLACK LIVES
MATTER.
IT DOESN'T MATTER.
YOU ARE LOOKING AT THE YOUTH
WING OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTIES.
THESE ARE THEIR SHOCK TROOPS.
LISTEN TO MAXINE WATERS AND CORY
BOOKER CALL THEM TO ARMS.
>> GO TO THE HILL TODAY.
GET UP AND IN THE FACE OF
CONGRESS PEOPLE.
>> IF YOU SEE ANYBODY FROM THAT
CABINET IN A RESTAURANT, IN A
DEPARTMENT STORE, AT A GAS
STATION, YOU GET UP AND YOU TELL
THEM THEY ARE NOT WELCOME!
>> Tucker: GO GET THEM.
GET IN THEIR FACE.
THEY OBEYED.
THE LEFT ALWAYS OBEYS.
OBEDIENCE IS THE POINT OF THEIR
PROGRAM.
>> YOU WON'T EAT IN PEACE.
>> ABOLISH ICE.
>> [SHOUTING].
>> WELL, THANKS TO INCIDENTS
LIKE THE ONE YOU JUST SAW AND
THE ONE THE "WASHINGTON POST"
ASURES YOU ARE DIDN'T REALLY
HAPPEN.
YOU HAVE NO RIGHT TO BE WORRIED
ABOUT.
PEOPLE ACROSS THE COUNTRY
NEVERTHELESS ARE BECOMING CO
CONCERNED.
THAT'S ARREST -- THAT'S RACIST
SAYS THE POST.
THE WIFE OF SENATOR RAND PAUL IS
SO CONCERNED ABOUT WHAT IS
HAPPENING, SHE KEEPS A LOADED
GUN BY HER BED.
WATCH.
>> SO MANY UNHINGED PEOPLE AND
UNSTABLE PEOPLE OUT THERE.
WHEN THEY HEAR ON THEIR SIDE
TELLING THEM GET UP IN THEIR
FACE, THEY TAKE THAT LITERALLY.
THEY THINK THAT GIVES THEM A
LICENSE.
THAT SCARES ME.
WE UPDATED OUR SECURITY SYSTEMS
AT HOME AND I SLEEP WITH A
LOADED GUN BY MY BED.
I USED TO FEEL SAFE.
THAT'S CHANGE.
>> Tucker: THE "WASHINGTON POST"
MIGHT CALL HER PARANOID.
MANY ON THE LEFT CELEBRATED WHEN
HER HUSBAND WOUND UP IN THE
HOSPITAL AFTER BEING ASSAULTED
BY AN ANGREAL LIBERAL.
-- ANGRY LIBERAL.
>> MY HUSBAND HAD 6 BROKEN RIBS
AND WAS SERIOUSLY INJURED.
TO HAVE PEOPLE LIKE CHER AND BET
MIDLER LAUGHING ON THE INTERNET
AND LAUDING HIS ATTACKER, WHAT
KIND OF PERSON ARE YOU?
THAT YOU THINK THAT IS
ACCEPTABLE?
>> Tucker: THAT'S A FAIR
QUESTION.
THE VIDEO WE JUST SHOWED YOU IS
REAL VIDEO.
WE DIDN'T MAKE IT UP IN THE
BASEMENT TO SCARE YOU OR TO WIN
A MID-TERM.
ASSESSING EVERYTHING YOU HAVE
SEEN, YOU MIGHT BE TEMPTED TO
CONCLUDE THAT MAYBE THERE IS A
GROWING PROBLEM WITH LEFT WING
MOB VIOLENCE.
BUT LEFT WING LEADERS AND THEIR
PROPAGANDA IN THE PRESS
CONCLUDED THE EXACT OPPOSITE.
THEY HAVE DECIDED THE PROBLEM IS
ACTUALLY YOU.
YOU ARE THE PROBLEM SITTING AT
HOME.
YOU ARE DANGEROUS.
THE "NEW YORK TIMES" PAUL
GRUDMAN ACCUSED THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY OF HARBORING AUTHORIAN
IMPULSES.
HILLARY CLINTON IS SO WORRIED
ABOUT THE ANGRY GRANDMOTHERED IN
PORTLAND SMASHING WINDOWS, SHE
KNOW LONGER CONSIDERS
REPUBLICANS AMERICANS OR FULLY
HUMAN.
ACCORDING TO HILLARY CLINTON YOU
NO LONGER HAVE TO BE CIVIL TO
REPUBLICANS.
YOU CAN DO WHATEVER YOU WANT TO
THEM BECAUSE THEY DESERVE IT.
>> YOU CAN'T BE CIVIL WITH A
POLITICAL PARTY THAT WANTS TO
DESTROY WHAT YOU STAND FOR AND
CARE ABOUT.
I BELIEVE IF WE ARE FORTUNATE
ENOUGH TO WIN BACK AND/OR THE
SENATE, THAT'S WHEN CIVILITY CAN
START AGAIN.
>> Tucker: YEAH, SO THERE YOU
HAVE IT.
THERE IS THE MOST RECENT
DEMOCRATIC PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATE.
THE LEADER OF HER PARTY
ENDORSING VICIOUSNESS AGAINST
HER POLITICAL OPPONENT.
ACCORDING TO THE "WASHINGTON